موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله يجري ممثلون وقناصله من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول اخرى اليوم زياره
الى المسجد الاقصى ومن المقرر ان يلتقي
الوفد الاوروبي مسؤولي نافي دائره الاوقاف
الاسلاميه تهدف زيارته الى التاكيد على
موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي بشان ضروره الحفاظ
على الوضع القانوني والتاريخي القائم في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك
ويزور وفد من اعضاء مجلس الشيوخيه
الامريكيه اسرائيل اليوم وافادت وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه وامريكيه بان رئيسه
الوفد سنه
طلبت عدم اشتراك ممثلين عن حزب العظمه
اليهوديه وحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه اللذين
يتراسهما كل من من غير وثم خلال اجتماعات
الوفد باسرائيل
اندلعت مواجهات بين قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وفلسطينيين في مدينه نابلس
خلال اقتحام قوات الاحتلال للمنطقه
الشرقيه للمدينه لتامين اقتحام المستوطنين
ما يعرف بمقام يوسف
قوات الاحتلال القربه مخيم بلاطه شرقيه
المدينه
قالت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز نقل عن مسؤولين
امريكي
في اسرائيل وكوريا الجنوبيه لتلبيه حاجه
اوكرانيا الماسه من قضايا في المدفعيه
وذكر المسؤولون الاستخدام المخزونات
الامريكيه في اسرائيل جاء بسبب عدم تمكن
صانعي الاسلحه الامريكيين من مواكبه وتيره
العمليات القتاليه الاوكرانيه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه لا يمكن ان
تقديم الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا هو قرار
سياديا لكل بلد واضاف لينكن ان الهدف من
تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح والوصول الى وضع
يسهل على الطرفين الانخراطه في المفاوضات
من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء الهولندي
قررت انفاق مليارين ونصف المليون يورو
بشكل اضافي في اطار المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا واضاف انه هولندا تنوي الانضمام
الى برنامج بيجريوت لتعزيز النظام الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني في المقابل قالت الخارجيه
الروسيه تردد بشكل والتوقيت المناسبين على
اي اعمال غير يوديه ضدها من قبل الدول
الغربيه
قال وزير الخارجيه السويديه توبايس
بالسروم ان بلاده سوف تشروطه التي تضمنها
اتفاق التفاهمي الموقع العام الماضي مع
تركيا واكد بيلترم في تصريح للجزيره ان
الكره الان في ملعب انقره للبدء في
اجراءات التصديق على عضويه السويد في
النيتو
من جانبه دعوى وزير الخارجيه التركيه
مولود شاوش اوغلو والسويد للالتزام
بتعاهدتها في مكافحه التنظيمات التي
تعتبرها انقر ارهابيه وقال ان الخياره
الان بيدهم
انتهى الموجز انا ما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم
بكل خير